pues lo más importante lo que se espera
de acuerdo con el gran objetivo de la
presidencia del reino unido- de estar
con 26 es mantener vivo el acuerdo de
parís y como lo mencionas ese gran gol
es el gran objetivo de mantener
controlada la temperatura del planeta en
1.5 grados aquí continúan las
negociaciones están uno de los puntos
más álgidos más complejos porque son más
de 600 personas que están reunidas a
puerta cerrada pocos metros de donde nos
encontramos desde donde estamos
originando esta transmisión de france 24
que representan a más de 200 o cerca de
200 países que tienen diferentes
posiciones sobre cómo llegar a su
objetivo así que de ahí la dificultad el
secretario general de la onu antonio
gutiérrez ha insistido desde el día 1 de
esta con 26 en la importancia de ser
ambiciosos ha insistido hoy por ejemplo
en que debe haber más en la ambición en
mitigación adaptación y finanzas hasta
el momento de acuerdo con lo que ha
revelado el borrador conocido del
acuerdo del glasgow esos objetivos no se
cumplen pero por fortuna todavía se
cuenta con más de 24 horas para lograrlo